in today's money watch we're talking
about how to prepare for a potential
recession with inflation at a 40-year
high many experts warn of a possible
economic slowdown in a new poll 42
percent of Americans say they are
struggling to remain where they are
financially that is the highest
percentage we have seen in the past five
years only nine percent say their
financial situation is improving CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
joins us now Jill good morning good
morning so interesting the feds raised
interest rates uh jobs people are at
companies are adding jobs and yet we say
that we're heading towards a recession
are we headed towards a recession I
think the likelihood is really
increasing and it's the combination of
those four decade highs in inflation
because then all of a sudden businesses
and consumers start shifting their
behavior some they're going to pull back
and also the higher interest rates
chasing in chasing inflation by the FED
can often lead to the economy slowing
down too much we've talked about this
where we say the FED goes too fast they
slow things down too much and boom we're
in a recession here's what is clear even
if we don't go into this classic
definition of a recession things are
going to slow down and we want people to
be prepared for that slowdown so how
should people be prepared well I think
that while things are still pretty good
and while the job market remains solid
it's a great time to go back to the
basics and you know I have these boring
three concepts Gail King I'm looking at
you right now I didn't use the word
boring I know well they are let's just
say they're Classics and the classics
are we want people to have an emergency
Reserve fund and this was vitally
important during the pandemic we learned
this lesson and people built their
savings up enormously during the
pandemic there was not a lot to spend
money on six to 12 months of your living
expenses in a safe boring bank CD
savings money market account and by the
way if you're retired maybe it's one to
two years of those expenses so you don't
have to dip in we want people to pay
down credit card debt in a rising
interest rate environment servicing debt
costs more so that's really important if
you've got those two things covered then
great put some more money into your
retirement account it's a really good
time to get into that habit and I always
say how do you do this when you're
living paycheck to paycheck I remember
back in the day I would use a pay the
cable bill to the phone company pay the
phone company electricity because I
figured that would buy me some time they
would think well she's trying to pay it
and by the time the check comes back to
you then you think okay now I can do it
but how do you do this Jill save six to
12 months well I think it is really a
lot easier today because we can automate
our savings we can actually say to a
bank or a financial institution take
five or ten bucks out and it's really
easy to do you start small you go slowly
and you know what there are also some
other big decisions you can make you
could say hey I was going to buy
something big and maybe I won't do that
right now hey I was going to move out of
my parents house maybe I won't do that
until I get my reserves built up a
little bit I think it's important for us
to try to make these changes while we
can where are you in the question of
whether people should switch jobs or
leave their job if they're not happy at
this particular moment I am really at
this point where I think we have to
understand the labor market is Shifting
so we now know the first three months of
the year half a million jobs a month
were created the next three months it
was down to 380 000. that means workers
still have an advantage there's 11.3
million open jobs but before you just go
for an extra Buck an hour I would be
very careful you may have a great boss
you may have flexibility you may have an
ability to actually upskill yourself
with some classes that your boss is
going to pay for I think before you just
jump to the next job remember when the
economy rolls over what often happens is
the last person in is the first one to
go really quickly for the sophisticated
investor does this represent a buying
opportunity in the stock market well I
would say this it's a 40-year high in
inflation prices are up overall what is
the one thing that down stocks and bonds
so if you can afford it then I think
it's a great time to up that
contribution into your retirement
account thanks sophisticated you mean
Rich
well if you can bear the wrists in my
old profession that's right Jill thank
you very much always a pleasure